Following a modestly successful release, The
Shawshank Redemption has gone on to become
one of the most beloved and acclaimed movies
ever made.
It often sits atop all-time best lists and
boasts performances for the ages from Tim
Robbins as quiet, new inmate Andy Dufresne
and Morgan Freeman as wizened lifer Red.
The cinematic adaptation of Stephen King's
novella is a simply told, deeply affecting
drama set in the imposing prison namesake,
and at its core, is a film about the impossibility
of caging the human spirit.
As beloved as the movie is, though, there
are some secrets about Shawshank many fans
don't know.
Framing a relationship
While many filmmakers have put Stephen King's
stories onto celluloid, the author hasn't
always been a fan of these adaptations.
For example, he famously hated Stanley Kubrick's
version of The Shining, calling its lack of
character arc a "tragedy," and saying he "could
do without all the Children of the Corn sequels."
Nevertheless, he encourages new filmmakers
to adapt his work by offering young directors
the rights to his short stories for just one
dollar.
In the early 80s, Frank Darabont paid his
buck to adapt "The Woman in the Room" and
gained some screenwriter cred by writing films
like A Nightmare on Elm Street 3 and The Blob.
Bolstered by his success in the business,
Darabont approached King again, only this
time asking about the Shawshank Redemption.
Evidently, King enjoyed Darabont's take on
"The Woman in the Room" so much that he sold
the Shawshank rights for a mere $1,000.
However, King never even cashed the check.
Instead, he had it framed and gave it back
to Darabont as a gift.
Darabont has since gone on to direct other
adaptations of King's books, including The
Green Mile and The Mist, but he almost lost
his shot at Shawshank just as soon as he got
it.
After writing the script for the adaptation
of Shawshank Redemption, Darabont sent the
screenplay to Castle Rock Entertainment, the
production company run by Rob Reiner.
Reiner had successfully directed two Stephen
King stories before -- Stand By Me and Misery
-- and loved the script so much that he offered
Darabont $3 million to take it off his hands.
After all, Darabont had only helmed one actual
move at this point, a made-for-TV endeavor
called Buried Alive, so Castle Rock also promised
to finance any film of Darabont's choice.
However, the young director wouldn't change
his mind, taking a lesser sum and the directorial
duties that went along with it to create one
of cinema's most cherished movies and a long-lived
career behind the lens as well.
Taking the lead
Though he wouldn't be directing the movie,
Rob Reiner did have a hand in the casting,
offering the role of Andy to none other than
Tom Cruise.
The two had worked together in 1992's Oscar-nominated
A Few Good Men.
While the superstar was definitely intrigued
by the project, he didn't want to work with
an inexperienced director like Darabont, even
though he'd later work with him in 2004's
Collateral.
After Cruise passed, the role was offered
to other celebrated stars such as Tom Hanks,
Kevin Costner, and Nicolas Cage, all of whom
said no.
Eventually, the part made its way to Tim Robbins,
and now, it's pretty much impossible to see
anyone else in the movie.
That wasn't the only case of casting twists
in Shawshank.
In Stephen King's original novella, the character
of Red was an Irish-American guy with, appropriately
enough, reddish-gray hair.
So when thinking about who to cast in the
part, Darabont considered two of his favorite
older, white actors: Gene Hackman and Robert
Duvall.
However, neither actor could accept the part,
so that's when Castle Rock producer Liz Glotzer
suggested going with Morgan Freeman.
Darabont loved the idea, and Freeman signed
on, eventually earning an Oscar nomination
for Best Actor.
And sure, his hair wasn't red, but Darabont
got around that by writing a joke to explain
the nickname.
"Why do the call you that?"
"Maybe it's because I'm Irish."
If you didn't get that joke before, now you
do.
"hehehhehehehehehehhehe"
What's in a name?
When it comes to long titles, The Shawshank
Redemption is a bit of a mouthful.
"Why you calling the thing the Shawshank Redemption?
Nobody can say that."
Of course, the name could've been a whole
lot longer, as King's novella was called Rita
Hayworth and the Shawshank Redemption.
Darabont didn't change it for linguistic reasons.
Instead, he altered the name because he didn't
want to mislead casting agents—or actresses—into
thinking it was a bio-pic on '40s movie star
Rita Hayworth.
Hayworth's main "role" in the film is as a
poster covering up Andy's secret tunnel out
of prison, but early on in the production
process, Darabont received a slew of resumes
and headshots from actresses interesting in
playing the "title role," as well as an agent
who represented a supermodel trying to get
into acting.
He later said in the film's commentary track,
"That told us how carefully that agent had
read the script and how much hot air floats
around Hollywood from time to time."
And it also inspired the title change.
Hitting it big … later
These days, pretty much everyone loves The
Shawshank Redemption, but it wasn't a huge
box office success when it first came out.
The movie earned just $18 million in late
1994, and then another $10 million when it
was re-released into movie theaters in early
1995 after landing seven Academy Award nominations.
Fortunately for film fans everywhere, the
movie finally became a hit on home video.
Upon its initial release on VHS, Warner Brothers
manufactured and shipped 320,000 copies of
The Shawshank Redemption to video stores.
Despite competition like The Lion King and
Forrest Gump, The Shawshank Redemption became
the most rented video of 1995, eventually
grossing about $80 million in rentals, and
has lived on as an unshakable piece of Hollywood
nostalgia.
Saying thanks
At the end of The Shawshank Redemption—after
Andy and Red reunite—there's still one last
moving moment.
It's a dedication that reads, "In memory of
Allen Greene."
So who is this guy exactly?
Well, on the director's commentary track on
the Shawshank DVD, director Frank Darabont
explained that Greene was his first-ever agent.
As Darabont explained, in the '80s, he was
"...a set dresser on low-budget movies who
wanted to be a writer, and it's very hard
to get an agent to believe in you on that
level."
But when Darabont met Greene, he discovered
a friend and an ally.
Now sadly, Greene died of complications from
AIDS right before Shawshank started filming,
and that's why the director decided to pay
his friend tribute.
He said,
"I wanted to acknowledge not just his significance
to my career but also that he was an incredibly
decent, much-loved, and much-missed person
in the lives of those who knew him."
So, while Allen Greene had exactly nothing
to do with the actual movie, there's a reason
his name is so prominent in the dedication
line.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!